Big Tech has its eyes set on your wallet.
Apple has a credit card.
Facebook is trying to introduce its own currency.
And Google has plans to offer checking accounts...
...to users of its digital wallet in 2020.
So, tech firms are offering services...
...that are usually associated with banks, but they're doing it differently.
It's really about data.
When a company like Apple or Google processes a payment for you,...
...they find out a lot about you.
They know what you bought, where you bought it,...
...what time of the day or what day of the month...
...you're likely to spend money and that's really valuable information for advertisers.
Also, banking is another way for tech firms to draw customers...
...further into their universes.
So, Facebook started out as a way to talk to your friends,...
...and then became a place you shared baby photos with your grandparents.
And now you can shop on Facebook properties,...
...you can message, Instagram, WhatsApp.
Amazon is the same way.
It started out as a big store, and now they make home speakers,...
...they make original movies and television shows.
So, these companies all started off with one thing...
...and they're adding more things around it...
...and finance is kind of the last frontier.